Shawn Mendes you couldn't be more  amazing Wow  with those words in a heart emoji the  fans who are shipping this new  relationship we're heating up over the  weekend as Camila Instagram from both of  Shawn's sold-out LA shows then these new  photos dropped  oh my Mendes smiling from ear to hear  the two pop stars are spotted walking  hand-in-hand in LA and just look at that  embrace hugging it out for the world to  see so are their steamy scenes from  their new video senorita inspiring a  possible new romance are they just  playing it up in hopes of having their  hit song topple Old Town Road on the  Billboard charts  [Music]  kamilla did just split with boyfriend  Matthew Hussey back in June so summer  lovin could be in the air for her and  Shawn but at a fan event over the  weekend he shut that down pretty quick I  won't but I don't know you that's why